[Music]
argue that human rights should give us
hope and inspire us to stake our claims
and help everyone live a dignified life
I think hope supports this virtue of
creative resolve which is a fundamental
commitment to trying to find ways of
fulfilling rights creative resolve as a
personal as well as political virtue so
that it's the kind of thing that
individuals can have in their own
personal lives as well as as in working
together to bring about positive change
when each of us find obstacles to doing
things that we really believe it then I
think often we need to think creatively
about how can we change the problem or
look at the problem differently people
might ask well you know how how far do
you have to go with this you know aren't
we actually facing resource constraints
aren't there times and we have to let
people die and I think I was listening
to this podcast of a I think it was in
New Orleans where they had a hospital
and they had to do triage because the
the helicopters were coming to save
everybody and it was in the flood and so
there's this nurse who had resuscitated
somebody and she was pumping this oxygen
bag and the the doctor says her look
you're gonna have to let that guy go the
helicopters just aren't coming
and so she holds the sky in her arms
well he dies and I think that's the
point in which we should be before we
give up right that creative resolve
requires us to go all the way to that
edge you know there were 2,000 people or
something in that hospital who were
largely unoccupied for the 24 or 48 or
64 hours until those hot those
helicopters came and so you know
creative resolve but would think you
know how would we how would we keep
somebody pumping that oxygen bag for the
next day or two maybe we could line
people up and and take turns so I think
we have to make the hope for for human
rights and global health and that
requires each of us to you know think
creatively about ways of helping people
my own project is this global health
impact
project where we attempt to evaluate
pharmaceuticals consequences for global
health around the world and then create
incentives for companies and other
organizations to actually focus on
extending access out essential medicines
more broadly because they can receive
credit on on this reading system it's a
kind of human rights indicator that I
think could make a large difference the
later parts of the book I argue that
pharmaceutical companies are actually
violating rights and failing to live up
to their obligations when they set
prices that make it difficult if not
impossible for people to access
essential medicines and there's
alternatives to doing that I think
there's some more fundamental questions
about how do we restructure our research
and development systems to reward
innovation that actually has the right
kinds of consequences for global health
so rather than treating these chronic
diseases of rich patients where the the
pharmaceutical companies can make the
most money if we can give them
incentives to focus on the largest
health problems around the world I think
that would be absolutely fantastic and
so the idea of you know creating
something like a fair trade label that
pharmaceutical companies might love
because they could make more for
products that have these labels if
people are willing to incentivize them
to try to get that label based on having
a larger health impact that could be
pretty fantastic there's also a large
public health sort of side to what I'm
doing so if you know again if we know
where we're having an impact and where
we're not let's say the country level
that could be really important for
guiding the distribution of medicines or
focusing efforts to promote positive
change
[Music]